peu
[Musique]
grâce à l'abolition de l'anesthésique
obtenus par nos camarades par vos
camarades
après des années de lutte les
travailleurs les plus démunis vont
désormais pouvoir s'opérer eux mêmes
sans risquer de s'endormir pendant le
dépeçage le matin sandrine brouch a je
suis tourneur fraiseur hill 2 à vierzon
madame sandrine brochard va maintenant
réaliser devant vous sur son visage
grotesque la première intervention
d'auto chirurgie esthétique comment
c'est simple regardez bien
grâce à l'abolition de l'anesthésique
qui ouvre aux travailleurs les portes de
l'auto chirurgie les pauvres aussi ont
droit à la beauté que belle que moi tu
meurs
etonnant non
[Musique]